you know you don't write albums like on
a yearly basis
it takes a while before i get my music
from you
[Laughter]
i'm going to look at that i'm going to
really look at that no no it's all right
on time and it all is coming from
such an again organic place which i
think is why you've stood the test of
time and why
it you have such dedicated devotee
fans like myself because it's authentic
and you can't rush that right
yeah and so it's just got to be natural
and flow so
what brought this one on this one was
postpartum
i started it in malibu with onyx and
i mean i think of the song losing the
plot
uh and diagnosis as me just going okay
so i feel really pathologized i feel
you know everything about postpartum
unless someone's experienced it it's a
tough one to explain
people have a general sense of what you
mean when you say depressed or anxious
postpartum in general have whole other
elements to it of
these invasive thoughts and they're
terrifying
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose is
to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability
and what you realize is that we are so
much
more alike than we are different to
quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
today on the show is my favorite artist
of all time
alanis morissette i have been a fan of
hers for
obviously since the jagged little pill
days it's such an honor to be able to
interview her
i was lucky enough to finally meet her
in 2008 i think it was
at her concert but she's uh she's just
you'll hear in the episode she's just
such a deep fascinating person it's no
wonder that her music
is so meaningful interesting and so
resonant because there's just so much
emotion that goes into all of it
and so you'll get a really good glimpse
into
the way she thinks and the things that
she deals with her
orientation with that and and the music
itself
and how she processes and you know how
she processes on stage
she's a she's just a really fascinating
deep human being and it's just my honor
to finally interview her so please enjoy
the episode
so what what's up with the new haircut
it's so cute and blonde
i feel like i did that last summer
actually i went short and blonde
i saw that last time i saw you it was a
little yeah ombre action
you know pandemic
what else what else can we attribute
under this phrase
pandemic i'm pretty much everything at
this point
the whole i feel like everyone's
thighing out right now but then
realizing oh gosh what does it mean that
the world's gonna come back to being
something that
maybe it was before a little bit
adjusted now that we
spent the last year in what we were
doing wow what a time
right because it's not about actually
like because the the total phrase is
like oh when's everything gonna be
normal again but nobody really wants
actually what was normal
people want a new normal so the question
is is what is that new normal you know
and yes and it's up to us like to decide
collectively i guess
but you know take our time especially
those of us who have sensitive
temperaments right it's just slow
reintegration hopefully nothing has to
happen overnight but
i think uh for me it's about continuing
some of the self-care stuff
um that you had time for yeah
right if it's meditating or whatever it
is i speaking with my doctor yesterday
and she was like your cortisol levels
are pretty high and i said
yeah that feels about right we're all
reintegrating any second and
i said and how does one address this
she's like you know meditation sleeping
so i gotta start doing that again um
well what what
what uh why what's the strat what's
going what's the what's the cortisol
for for right now is there something
going on that
is new yeah i'm just playing with
hormones you know it's like
i'm breastfeeding but i'm also
perimenopausal to get
a little tmi for you right out of the
gate um so
playing with hormones and then not
sleeping a lot because i still feed
and nurse through the night and you know
just trying to be the
the primary breadwinning macro service
person
and the attachment mom on schooling
and then running a whole business and
you know how it is
trying to do a lot of different things
at once
you know it's not to bash men but women
have a lot of [ __ ] to do
and a lot of [ __ ] to deal with yes and
they you know there's the
what is it called like the secret load
the the mother lode
it's just you know all the things that
we do that we never really
acknowledge but it gets done every day
you know the subtle stuff like
totally even the social convening in
some ways i know some
all genders do that and non-genders but
something about being in charge of the
social tenure of our little community
here too that's its own full-time job
ah do you feel you feel like that's more
of a woman's more more like
women normally take charge of that or is
that just your role
um sometimes i think stereotypically
women in general
are a little more relational we're not
shamed for being relational as much
we're still shamed for being relational
and vulnerable but not as much
as men so um but in my
yeah and my role here is very much to
keep
you know you just i'm constantly just
checking to see what needs to be
addressed who needs to be hugged
and then i have some great therapists
for me and that's amen
amen for therapy moment of silence
yes i agree
i'm like i can't i actually i i i've
come around and around on therapy
because like
i did it 100 years ago when i was
married and then it just didn't end well
and then i was like screw therapy and
then
you know i went for a span of time that
there was none of that and then all of a
sudden it was like
all of a sudden after the last
relationship it was like
i need therapy and then i'm like wait a
second
people should always be in therapy and
you should be doing your
own therapy like i believe in couples
therapy sure
but not if you're not doing your own
well i think they kind of go together
because there are certain things
that you that i'm only going to dive
into if it's just about me in that
moment you know it's a
super deep dive some parts i do a lot of
ifs
internal family systems therapy and
what's great about that particular
model for me is that it's the deep dive
alone
facilitated by a great therapist and
then to me the idea of
couples ifs therapy meaning we can this
part of you can speak with this part of
me and is this like parts therapy or is
this a different kind of
is there any actual modalities used
other than sort of verbal and going
inward or is
is there this isn't something like emdr
or anything like that is it
uh it's a model it's richard schwartz
started it i just wrote the forward for
his new book that's coming out it's
called no bad parts
love it and i've been i've been a parts
girl for as long as i can remember i
just
you know if someone said ask me how i
was feeling i would say well one part of
me
feels this and the other 13 parts feel
this
but we have that even in our family with
my kids if i ask anyone how they're
feeling it's usually more than one
answer
that's interesting do you think that
that is and like
something they're born with or something
that you've taught them like do they
have you given them the tools to tap
into that or is it sort of a modeling
i think it's a straight-up curiosity
like how are you feeling
about that you know and what part of you
feels that or what part of you thinks
that that you know
it's just a curiosity about their parts
and then
because i know richard schwartz's model
so well and i'm obsessed with it
um it's just part of our family's
lingo now you know i mean parts work is
just you know
carl jung and then segwayed into debbie
ford really taking it to another level i
think her work really
blossomed it into culture a little more
and then richard schwartz just taking it
to a whole other level
we're like casually dropping in here but
i feel like it's because we had
like two and a half hours when we did
the
lindsay zarniak um uh artist in the
athlete interview and we just sat there
and you and i i was like i felt kind of
bad for lindsay because
pluto didn't you know she didn't get a
word in very
much but like we just went on and on so
i feel like this
this interview is like a continuation of
the conversation we were having which
has so much to do with the internal work
and spirituality and
orientation and perception um
triggers projections all the damn words
all the damn words
but like it can't be missed that i'm
just such like
you're just as i was getting ready for
this it's like man
you are my all-time favorite artist and
so i'm like pausing for a moment to
remember
how much i just like love your music so
i know that we just like
totally dropped into all kinds of things
they feel like people should just know
how big of a fan i am
and how um how interesting it is how
much we resonate on this other level
that really is like
you know nothing to do with essentially
it's not music we're not talking about
an album we're not talking about a tour
although i want to and we will
uh because i have like tickets from all
directions for the tour
that's all i know i think that's
interesting
how i can be such a big fan and here we
are
on in this whole other way connecting
why do you think that is
do you think is there some kind of
resonance that is unspoken
yeah i think and sometimes we do speak
it you know it's just it's
it's a value system so i think what we
value
is is resonant and if we want to break
down what some of those are
you know we value i value connection and
i believe you do too
just even your capacity for intimacy and
and connection and wanting to
even have a bond you know our our
survival strategies might be similar we
love to
we love conversation we might we might
be the same number on the enneagram i
have no idea
um but also i think you and i are up for
the deep dive of
diving into the unknown you know
there's a there's a sort of
constitutional type of
temperament and spirit i think and for
you know
this the symbology of pedal to the metal
foot on the brake i mean that's me all
the time i'm
i'm going 100 miles an hour and then i
realize i have to stop and
the gears are grinding but i'm like oh
sorry i'm using this freaking metaphor
with you of all people
you should it's totally so not sorry i
think you and i
have the similarity of curiosity too and
i like to just know the
the lowest common denominator i love
breaking things down to their essence or
to
you know to why something why i was
acting out in a certain way or why i was
quiet and you know i just i'm really
curious
um about this human condition you know
it's not always easy to be in these
these meat sacks i love the little
there's like a little gif or meme or
whatever it is and it's
it shows uh somebody down on earth in a
little bubble of thoughts like like
this coming to earth thing was a lot
harder than i thought it'd be
right amen yeah it's really hard my aunt
and i we communicate a lot and she's
always like why did you come here this
is an
interesting journey for for everyone
frankly
you know but it's you know there's some
tools as we know
but trying to figure out toolfulness in
the from ego is already kind of set up
to lose in a way if
if the goal is to be just happy you know
if the goal is to be just
one state i don't think emotional states
were built to be constant i mean they're
all messenger
you know messengers and messages for us
so for me it's about the degree of
listening and tuning in
and when i'm not doing it i feel
disconnected from god and from myself
and from my loved ones and it doesn't
it's not a comfortable feeling that's
when it's not fun to be in the body for
me
but when the connection is fostered and
i am
you know looking at different parts and
communicating from this really really
soulful place that i can feel connected
to life and everyone around me but
it's uh you know the the the chase of
the happiness thing was really trendy
for like 50 years
and i think it's i think now it's the
for me the chase
if there is an egoic chase it's to stop
resisting
how hard it is to be human sometimes and
how beautiful it is too
is your aunt alive you said
communicating okay i wasn't
sure if you were oh yeah i do that too
but she happens to be in her body
it's so funny you know what's so funny
is before this i was like
i thought i'm like i wonder what you're
like if you have what your psychic
capacity is
yeah i mean i can definitely i can
conjure it
i mean i don't do it a lot but ever
since i was very little i can
i don't know what what the term would be
i do have a capacity to
hear messages or connect with people
who aren't in the body or i have to be
careful though so i think it's
it's being an empath so 30 of people
highly sensitive
um and then of that 30 20 to 30
um four percent of them are empaths and
some of them are
medium type impasse some of them are
animal and past plant empaths you know
and they're linked to the intelligences
so you asked about my capacity and it's
really
i think it's a gift you know it's scary
sometimes to be picking up so much
information no matter what and that's
one of the stresses cortisol
for the reintegration into this new
normal is
the idea of like wow okay i have to
i have to pace myself and you know i
just pick up on
so much information that i you know i
just have to prepare myself for hiding
in bathrooms again
yeah i well i mean i think that that's
that's more
i mean there's there's people out there
that deal with that i mean i have a
couple of friends who just you know pick
up a lot of energy and
it's not how i work but um
uh what are the tools because i
i feel like there's got to be someone
that's like oh my god that's me i walk
around and there's all this information
and it's so overwhelming
and then i feel like that also
contributes to
you know how much anxiety is out there
in the world and how many people suffer
with anxiety because that's a real thing
and
i didn't actually i mean i didn't
experience it until
last year a couple of times and i was
like oh my god what is this
like full-blown panic attack you mean or
um like
unable to get out of a thought like i
couldn't choose a good thought
right like i was sort of like spinning
ruminating yeah yeah
exactly and it just kind of created a
lot of
like you know body heart rate panic
um yes like rampant journaling all of a
sudden trying to get something out
and i had never i'd i mean i really only
had it probably three times
but it was it gave me this new
understanding for what it's like to pick
up energy because it was when i was
picking up the energy
of something else and someone else that
it would happen
and so you know i think that's uh that's
something
people really deal with and it's hard to
find your way out of it and there's
there have been so many more books and
and much more literature
being made available now about about
being an empath there's a woman rose
rose tree who's written
a few books i think one of them was
called empowered empath the master
empath
um you know and and there's different
schools i i
really enjoy when the distinction is
kept between empath and hsp
because um they're not the same
what's the difference um highly
sensitive temperament you know the
acronym that elaine aaron goes with um
she
coined the phrase and is a brilliant
brilliant mind and heart
um and i had the privilege of of being
in a documentary that she made entitled
sensitive
and and one of the best ways she
describes it is by the acronym does
so d for depth of processing for a
highly sensitive
um o for overstimulation or quickly over
stimulated in that as an hsp i can walk
in the room and
if a non-hsp were to pick up 50
pieces of information upon walking into
a room in theory the highly sensitive
temperament picks up on 500 pieces so it
would make sense then that
highly sensitives need to kind of pace
ourselves and
recalibrate it doesn't take me long
either there are some nights where i'll
turn to my son and my husband and i'll
just say
if i don't have six minutes of complete
silence i'll be back in six minutes
you know i can't even be here my head's
gonna pop off emoji
so um and the the
the retelling of the soil can happen
really quickly and then the empath
sorry i didn't finish the acronym then e
for um
empathy you know a tendency to word
being extra empathic
um and and deeply felt emotions you know
like sometimes
someone will feel something and i'll
feel it in my chest it feels almost
debilitating you know
and um not everyone feels it so
debilitatingly in the
in the body um and then s for subtleties
sort of attuned to subtleties and
you know picking up on certain smells
and all the senses basically
um and then empath is just a different
kind of attunement
and awareness and and the picking up of
people's energy or
you know i used to have it as a kid too
i remember once my brother hurt his
ankle
and then i couldn't walk you know so i
would have sort of this physical
body empath thing but in rose rose
tree's book she literally breaks down
the kinds of empaths and the good news
and the confusing news is that there are
a lot of books coming out right now and
most of them agree with each other but
it's
the exciting thing is that it's part of
the conversation now because in the
psychotherapeutic community no one
wanted to talk about
two things they didn't want to talk
about they didn't want to talk about
attachment parenting
and attachment theory which i think now
we're kind of blending it together as as
humans um
and they also no one wanted to touch
temperament i don't know why
until elaine aaron came around so the
more we can talk about this i think the
better
because there are all these artists in
the 27 club and people committing
suicide
and depression and anxiety i mean it's
so much of it
is born from being sensitive and
from being an empath and if we're not
equipped to even understand what that is
we're subject to thinking that you know
we're cursed or that there's something
wrong with us or when the opposite is
true
you know we do have to be responsible
for it though you know i have to be
really clear about what i need in order
to do something and that could be
that could be as simple as is there a
room that has a door that i can go in
at the office that we're going to yes
okay great
i can go you know but if there's nowhere
to hide or there's nowhere to regroup
it's
it's a rough one yeah you just said a
couple of things a few things that i
feel like i've been diving into so much
over the last year
being like attachment theory and
attachment styles
um and i the difference between that
parent and
your own your own attachment style and
parenting attachment
um how because i would lock them into
the same like you just have an
attachment style
and you get it from your parents but
what is the difference between
attachment parenting and attachment
theory um well for me they're
they're bed the bed they're bedfellows
you know so
attachment parenting is what it actually
looks like
you know so it could be anything that
that just basically fosters the bond so
i yes it could be breastfeeding but it
could be bottle it could be anything
contact skin eye contact super
attunement
responsivity frankly i would throw in
gentleness
and anything that would create a secure
bond to the point where they'll
i love watching when it whence the
secure bond is being out of
evidence it's not always but when it is
i love it because you know they'll come
sit on my lap they'll get the the love
the oxytocin and then they'll say bye
and then they're off
and it's the greatest i mean that's
secure attachment but
you know i'm my attachment style is a
little bit ambivalent sometimes
disorganized
um and it's just born from a different
style of having been
raised i think in the 70s and 80s it was
just a different world and
you know there was a lot more onus i was
thinking about this yesterday
there's so much onus on partners
prioritizing each other above the kids
and on paper that sounds great
however good luck because your kids are
developing in a way you know the inner
child of my husband let's say
the inner children of my husband he can
deal with it in therapy i can deal with
it with him and couples therapy
but these young little creatures are a
hundred percent dependent on us for
their development of their brain and
their bones and their body and their
empathy and their
there's a lot of studies now that say
that they continue to need it in a
pretty primary way
not just you know they turned 18 so get
out of here to the point where it's
almost 10 years later like
late 20s is when i think
there's a natural segueing into okay now
i'm ready to fully differentiate and go
out into the world
but that's a lot higher of a number than
we used to allow for right it was like
okay you get your license at 16
all these passages that we're supposed
to just barrel through
but i think the the attachment
conversation never goes away i think
it's really really present
in romantic committed partnerships i
mean that's where we see where our
styles
totally you know resonate or deviate or
and you know if the the the ambivalent
one
can can cause the come here go away the
secure one's lovely you know a nice eye
contact and
connectivity and the ability to be
vulnerable and listen to each other
non-judgmentally i mean
secure is the idea and certainly there's
such thing as being
an earn secure you know like you can do
a lot of you
like what you're doing and what i do you
know we can
we can earn that sense of security um as
an adult which is the best news because
you know the whole thing of you can't
you can't live your childhood over again
it's like you can't but there is healing
available
right well i love to say you know that
you know
our wounds are not our fault but our
healing is our responsibility
you know thank you it just happens
everybody's got a certain style
everybody's got something
and um you know when my therapist told
me last summer nobody holds a key so i'm
like
oh [ __ ] like i'm just gonna sit here and
wait to see if that's true for 20. i
gotta do all this myself
can i just yeah can i just wait it out
for a little bit and see how this goes
but i do think that we're i think what's
becoming
cool and trendy now thank god not a
moment too soon
is that we are becoming really clear
pandemic and all we're it's becoming
really clear that we do need each other
right this whole autonomous like you got
to do it yourself and
if you don't love yourself how is anyone
going to love you it's like
okay that's a little more easily done
for me
in parts work because then
the perspective that i'm communicating
with these parts from
you know it the invitation for me is to
be in that high capitalist self
the highest self that has as richard
schwartz calls it you know all the seas
so
creative centered you know confidence
um curious so i love all that because
when i'm
in that state it means that i'm in my
you know
whatever we want to call it my highest
self and then i can behold
and dialogue with these parts which is
my favorite thing to do
um but sometimes i'm not and sometimes i
think i'm in my seat but
it's these other parts that are trying
to come in and they they try to blend
you know so it's really about being
discerning like what part of me is
saying this
what part needs attention what part
is this terrified part and can i create
a little
distance you know eckhart tolle would
call it disidentifying a little bit with
the thought
but also with the part some can i create
some disidentification
with this part so i can actually
dialogue with it you know
so it's heady stuff but once
once it becomes habitual it's it's
mandatory for me when i'm
if i don't do any kind of inner work for
a few days in a row i'm
my personality just sucks
[Laughter]
well i doubt that's true um
but when did that i mean like the the
biggest question always is like
where did it start like was there like
something that happened a catalyst
a breakdown because the spiritual
journey
the self-reflective journey is
um usually i mean it's
some sometimes it takes a trigger um
and perhaps maybe it's an always been in
you but was there something that
led you down this path because once you
get on the train like you never get off
right right
no i feel like that's too exciting
anyone i know that gets into
spirituality
and into working on themselves and like
you never stop
and there really is no end i love like
uh i
love um abraham hicks saying you can't
get it wrong and it's never done
like it's just never done no i know you
know yeah it's relaxing hearing that
actually
um and you can't get it wrong because
it's all part of the journey even the
lows
are able to alchemize into something
beautiful like sometimes you need the
extra low
to actually have a grind yeah to get it
out
break down break it open yeah so was
there is there any kind of story around
it
well i think first of all i actually
think the capacity to go inside
to journey into the interiority there's
so many fun pretty ways to say it
you know the going within muscle you
know um i actually think that's an
intelligence howard gardner uh
calls it intrapersonal intelligence so
inter
personal relational and then intro like
the capacity to go within and
and see what's going on in there um i
mean that's a propensity that's an
intelligence i think so we either have
it and we sublimate it or i
you know do any any version of addiction
to like just
numb out so i don't have to go in there
because sometimes it's scary
but i have found that when i go in there
with support
whether it's a therapist or a loved one
or
it's a lot easier and i remember i may
have shared this with you
when we spoke last um but i remember one
time my son
who's now 10 he was probably three
and he was feeling a lot of feelings and
i said hey you want to go in there
together and see what's going on in your
heart you know and he said oh i don't
want to go in there it's so scary
and i said well i'll go in with you you
know and then he and he said okay
but just the idea that it's scary to go
within is a pretty pervasive message in
culture in general
so to have that muscle already kind of
cooking
is helpful and i'm actually really
comfortable in there
you know it's it's humans that scare me
so you know it it just increases my
bravery the more i know what's going on
and the more informed i am and the more
frankly
a loving objective person who's willing
to share their advice or their
opinion about what they see is a big
deal because the the developmental stage
is
crassly put from margaret mahler and
harper hendricks and a few other people
i mean it's attachment and then
exploration
so you want freedom and safety in there
and the attachment
as secure as possible then it's identity
who are who am i and the only way we
know when we're littles
is if people are reflecting back like
wow that was really strong or wow that
was really brave or
oh are you feeling sad about that or you
know someone who's just
using words to mirror basically and i
think that is one
stage of development that is egregiously
overlooked in people and then some of us
wander around
wondering why we're codependent quote
unquote or why we're
losing ourselves in relationships or we
don't have a sense of self you know and
that mirroring part and then the fourth
one in theory is is competence
like you can do it you know so so of
those four main ones that i
that i reference in the back of my mind
um
mirroring is the one that that is the
most deeply touching for me just because
i appreciate it and
maybe it's it's part of our canadian
culture too i think a lot of people are
quick to just
say what they see and i think it's a
great gift um
but i don't know why i shared that
probably just because the uh
that that was a big part of continuing
to cultivate the
ability to go internally was to have
someone almost marking it with me so
that
so that i wasn't alone because it was so
trendy to be autonomous for
you know after the second world war all
of a sudden women were like this is
great that you've been gone i've learned
how to
live without you and now it's cool to
just be singular
it's cool to not need a partner it's you
know so it's a big trend toward
um autonomy basically but and that's
wonderful and maybe empowering in some
ways but it
doesn't create love it doesn't create
healing as much as it
increates it sort of cultivates
empowerment which of course we love
but that's incomplete without without
being able to lean on each other
you know so the the real thing is like
when did that journey start
was it after jagged little pill was it
when you were a kid
was it writing music starting at 10
years old like
i mean where did it start well i think
the archetype of artist you know i was
always painting and
writing hilariously terrible poems oh my
god
um you know drawing i was just always
feel you know desperate to be expressed
actually so
that's that was one of the quickest ways
to pull myself out of these little
mini depressions that i started having
from probably 10 years old onward
i had an eating disorder and
i just went to a therapist myself and
that journey of realizing that you know
i always think of it in terms of tennis
playing like i just want to play tennis
with someone who's a little bit better
than me so that i can
you know so that i'm sweating i want to
sweat
so uh so therapy just kick-started this
you know thing also reading to be honest
i'm such a biblio girl
oh my gosh look behind you i mean hello
let's let's make the i've got literally
one shelf across the way
okay there's some up in the cupboard
because they don't all fit but i'm like
i need to work on my book collection
oh my gosh so so basically books were my
bffs because that you know they were
talking about things
these authors were all talking about
things that i lived for you know
wow what did you learn because it sounds
like perhaps
you know the eating disorder was maybe
part of it was there some big lesson
that came from
from that yeah i just i mean there's two
big ones that came during that time
a woman named
[Music]
karen koenig i think that's her name
uh wrote a book called breaking free
from
food something it was a green book and i
remember reading it cover to cover
dog ear it's probably here somewhere um
and that was really heartening and then
fat is a feminist issue suzy arbok i
think that came out when i was
a teenager so just starting to read
about
feminism and objectification and
hypersexualization i mean none of that
made any sense to me when i was younger
it was just painful
you know so i mean it's such a twisted
web to
i was just talking about this the other
day i'm like wait a second so
like we're supposed to
you know you know you're supposed to you
objectify
and use the woman's body but then you
get mad when she uses it herself like
you
you know what i mean like there's just
such complication it's like
you know look but don't touch kind of
thing and you know it's like
frowned upon and judged yet used and
exploited
and the whole thing is just so messy
well it's also egregiously incomplete
again like because
you know i don't i don't mind any of it
everything for the sake of art you know
enjoy as long as you're safe i guess
um but when i see a hyper-sexualized
music video or
performance i just think well as long as
everyone knows there's 650 000 other
parts to that person i suppose it's fine
you're like i'm not talking about the
grammys at all and what i saw on stage
no i mean it's just you know
hypersexuality is what it is you know
and
and if we're acting out that's maybe
something to look at but if we're not
i would just for me i just have empathy
and i just want everyone to know that
like you
we are so much more than just this
aesthetic and our
on our deathbeds i think that'll be
really clear that these bodies are
really cool and
let's decorate them and have fun with
them and make the hairs blonde and do
the fun stuff right it's the best
um i agreed i said that the other day i
was i was putting makeup on i'm like do
you think this is fun
always i'm like look at how silly this
is like this is what is this i'm putting
on
yeah is there gonna be a day we look
back and just go what were we doing
i don't think so i think we're just
going to think we were really cute
like i remember back in 2016
no i think i mean makeup is i love you
know
it's basically art yeah anything that's
aesthetic or whatever is it's a
beautiful for me it's part of
self-expression so
wearing sweatpants is part of
self-expression for me at this point
the sweatpants story dude
i have i i almost always put leggings on
today i had short i have like these
shorts that i went walking in just
because you know
they were out but normally it's leggings
for sure yeah yeah yeah
no and the other day i wore really tight
pants for some shoot
and i came home and i was like what's
wrong with me it's because it was the
first time i've been out of sweatpants
in a year
i just get afraid to put a pair on i'm
like i'm just like
if i put these on and they don't fit i'm
going to be so sad
so maybe i'll just keep wearing things
that stretch i think that's
really confident the best well until
until we're 112 then we can stop that
[Laughter]
no kidding so how does all of this like
play into music
because well first off do you really
what is it do you really love music
because i only ask it in that way
because like when people ask about my
career and it was over
i'm like it wasn't really racing that i
loved i loved aspects of it but it
wasn't really racing itself
well i think that's a really great
question and it's
um i loved writing when i was 10 years
old i just was
i couldn't fill enough journals up it
was just constant writing and then
after jagged little pill came out and
everything that became associated with
it so i started associating writing
songs with
touring and radio interviews at five in
the morning and
so they all kind of got locked in
together so some
so at certain points before i met my
husband i was
you know i i no longer i would no longer
write for fun basically was the point
and i would watch him and he's an artist
and he's just writing all the time the
guy writes a new record
every two weeks and so i asked him i was
you know in a way that was i'm sort of
envious like how do you
how could i be influenced by you and and
get that
joy back you know and and we really just
get we got to the bottom of it it's just
that i associate overwork
with art so if i can separate them
and uncouple them writing songs is so
fun it's
super hands palm sweaty
exhausting it feels uh glenn ballard
whom i have written with and wrote
jagged little pill with
he basically would his metaphor was you
know just getting the iv drip going
and then that's what songwriting was
like and and by the end of a song we we
would write and i still write really
quickly so the process is fast the
living of the life that's being
commented on is
protracted and apparently 46 years but
um
but the wrong the writing of the song
takes
20 minutes maybe it's really super
channeled and i don't i don't
i don't think i maybe more than once
have have gone back to fix anything or
tweak it or change it because it's just
a capturing
but to answer your question about
whether i
like it i think when i haven't done it
in a while
i yearn for it
i do i miss it terribly and making the
joyful noise you know singing and
sweating and
playing instruments and being with my
bandmates is the greatest we're about to
put a song out called i miss the band
and i can't get through it without being
a weeping mess and just picturing us all
reconvening over the next few months to
go on tour again
whenever that moment is um i'm just
gonna be a puddle i think
do you think when do you guys think
you'll tour
in 2021 or is this more like a 2022
rollout or
what's happening because i i will be
there
so maybe the whole thing i might like
put a sticker on the back of my car
and yes although is it a world tour
because if it is that'd be also awesome
the tour that was cancelled was the
world tour and we're gonna reinvigorate
the american part of it
with an eye toward probably trickling
into 2022
as everything becomes a little bit um
easier around travel
basically you know because it's just not
it's not possible to tour and have a
two-week warranty in
every new country that we get to it's
just not tenable but um
but the thought as of today this could
change it changes a lot um
is that we will go back on tour the end
of august or early september
of this year you know who else is a huge
fan of yours
that i found out the other day i don't
think he'd be mad that i said this
um i got a text like a week ago maybe
two weeks ago
and it was something he had seen the our
our interview with lindsay and he's like
oh my god he's like i love that
interview you did with alanis how cool
i'm such a big fan
dale earnhardt jr oh like a giant
giant fan and i was like man i had
tickets for so many shows like
because it was like for christmas but
everybody was getting me oh
things that i would like and a few
people got me tickets to your
that's awesome no um in different places
so
um so yes uh but i said we're gonna have
to like
get together and go see her when she
gets on tour and he's like i would love
that
oh awesome dale earner junior is such a
big fan
oh my god yeah he best not to tell me
who's in the audience because then i'll
get all
i'll get all jittery really
i have a lot of friends who do theater
and they specifically don't want to know
when i'm coming to see the show because
then you're just unconsciously aware of
that person i don't know if you have
that
but i definitely enjoy hearing who was
there
later after i think if there's
yeah i mean i can see that i guess what
i would say is that i
feel like when i'm put harder on the
spot when there's more pressure more
going on
i do better i would say that then when i
get into the mode of whatever it is that
i'm doing
it's like my consciousness shifts or
dimension shift and i and i
access a new space and i'm not thinking
at all about them
yeah so that's i mean that is a muscle
right there
that's the focus single focus muscle too
it's very masculine and quite gorgeous
is it because maybe there's pauses is
that do you enter a different space when
you get on stage is there
i mean well because even you know people
would say like someone was saying the
other day
seeing you backstage when you were young
and then like you'd get on stage and it
was just like
you know what i mean like yes someone
said like holding a teddy bear or
something like that back in the jagged
little pill days or something so
yes you know what happens is there
is it a natural transition into a
different space
or do you do something to get there yeah
i mean these are all amazing questions
god bless you danica
um i don't i mean i hug
my band mates and we'll have an
intention for the night if someone needs
extra love or
prayerfulness or anything will will
throw them into the intention behind the
show and
um but mostly we offer it up to the
people that are there
but that's the only real ritual i do my
friends used to laugh because i'd be
chatting with them and i'd be like okay
okay i'll be back in a minute you know
and then i'll just on stage
you're like wait a minute we were just
taking a minute you'll be back in two
hours
like you just you weren't even finished
your last sentence and you're halfway
out there um
so i guess my point in sharing that is
it
feels very the good news is i remember
gangaji talking about
you know meditating versus not
meditating and she said ideally
you know i'm sorry if i'm not using the
right words that she used but
she the essence of what she said was
ideally the meditation would just be
throughout your whole life and
throughout your day that everything
becomes a meditation
so so in that way being on stage
communicating even having a conversation
writing an email it it's all information
coming
from someplace and the good news about
being on stage for me is that it's a
very
physical release so it's an invitation
certainly for other people to
come join me in that process um and it
is
therapeutic and cathartic it's not
healing though because it's not
relational um because i used to think
like oh this is gonna be great i'll
write all these songs and i don't have
to talk to anybody it's perfect
um but there is something to be said for
just the expression itself moving the
energy so it doesn't get stuck and we
don't get sick
so it's like somatic kind of like
somatic healing on stage
it is 100 it's it's definitely that and
and then i allow the music to just take
over you know just take over my whole
body and
and there are times where i you know i
gotta knock on wood and
cross my fingers and everything but
there are there are nights where i'll
i'll have laryngitis and i can't even
speak
and then i'll just pray pray pray and
then i get out on stage and i have the
voice
and then i get off stage and i can't
speak again so there are times
i mean i don't want to jinx anything by
having said that but
but there are magical things that happen
is my point there's things that i just
can't believe are happening and
and um you know i do ask to be used
for service if i'm serving i can pretty
much
muscle my way i can white knuckle
through almost anything if i'm serving
what is that service that you want to
provide yeah well i mean what i would
invite
is uh is that their full humanity would
be allowed
in the room and the audience and the
interaction that
that they would feel safe to move with
me or
if some lyric or some chord choice that
universal language of music if
something were to conjure an emotion in
them that that they're safe to feel it
you know if they need to cry through the
whole song or the show if they need to
rage out and i can feel it it's a sweet
energetic dialogue you know
i can tell a little bit about people's
cultures a little bit just by
how emotive they are or aren't or you
know it's it's a fascinating cultural
study to be on stage to be honest
but there is that point i think it's
what you said where you get into that
place and nothing
nothing can interrupt that flow then you
know and it's the current i mean i i
call it the current
sometimes and and the speed with which
it goes through
our bodies literally as filters is
something that i'm fascinated with
because
some of us you know their energy is
going so fast that you know
bumping into things and um i know a lot
of artists that it's almost a mania
you know it's like wow okay it's a lot
of energy but um
you know the key for me it's like how to
fill the cup
how to you know and sleep sleep is
number one and it's the hardest one for
me
that's a good that is that's an
interesting question what is it that
fills your cup
up sleep does sleep keep you balanced or
does it fill your cup
up depends on how great the sleep was
depends on how cozy the blankets are um
in the cuddles yes the snugs i mean
sleep brings me to ground zero
um allison armstrong used to talk about
how
needs bring us to zira and then wants
take us into that sort of happy state a
little bit
um that kind of dopamine reward-y thing
but um yeah i i do a lot of
hot water it could be the sound of water
i think sensitives are are really
recharged by
being near the ocean or ions or lakes or
fountains anything you know tea soup hot
showers
you know you're you know what that's
interesting because i think
for me like the friends that are really
more empathic or
there's probably one that's more
empathic and the other one's probably
highly sensitive
um and they both love water like i mean
one of them loves mountains too
but um yeah yeah one of them in
particular really loves water
yeah it's a it's a thing like if i'm not
around it or i haven't gone swimming or
i haven't
gone to a creek or something i start i
start getting really
what about just earthing what about just
putting your feet on the ground and just
simply earthing actually you know what's
so funny my girl haley
who's worked with me forever she got me
this mat
hang on and my feet are on it right now
but it's like
a grounding mat that you put your feet
on so
and you can sleep with them too i have
sheets that are grounding sheets and you
plug that you ground them into
the outlet and then it just um the
stillness
yeah yeah so anyway my feet are on i'm
in i'm i'm googling this right after
yeah yeah
grounding sheets grounding pads it's
called earth and moon
no a lot of bare i'm barefoot almost all
the time when i can be
we have gardens and that's how that
helps but water still trumps everything
for me i think
yeah what have you found that's like
been part of your
routine that has stood the test of time
or at least really you know because we
go through i go through phases i don't
know about you but
i go through phases of things that just
seem like they're working or maybe i
need it now and then it fades out and
then it might come back
but what sticks around all the time
that's tried and true that you're like
if i can't do this
um i know that i start to lose
orientation with
where i'm at and how things are going
yeah i mean food high nutrient you know
people ask me what i am and i just say
i'm a nutritarian
i like nutrients so if food is off
i'm off um sleep obviously the classics
but um silence you know just
three kids unschooling at home
big career a lot of hyper communication
around here
in a really beautiful way but it's just
a lot of incoming information so for me
if i can just
find a place to be still and i have to
admit
i used to watch my brother wear earplugs
and i was just in awe i was like you
were just walking around wearing
earplugs like who cares and he said yeah
it's great
so i tried it last week and it brought
my anxiety up because i'm
i'm hyper vigilant and i wasn't able to
hear as well but it also calmed me down
so quickly super regulated are you a
gemini right aren't you gemini
yeah you love information yes yes and
sometimes
oh my god it's your dualistic issue in
life you love information yet there's
too much information
why does earth do this to us it's not
fair
i think i think earth also delivers
these amazing authors and supports
that can orient us i just you know i
wished it happened a little earlier
but here we are you know and how to
manage it
how to manage this situation you know so
that
i'm still capable of being relational
but i'm still
human you know the the fallibility of
being human and that i could be sitting
across from someone who would love me
and not judge
what's going on the other thing too for
the self-care one is touch
non-sexual touch specifically for i mean
sexual
is healing if it's if it's consent happy
happy
um but just touch massage
you know just like so are you i mean
five love languages is obviously such a
universal book and
you know ground zero for exploration but
do you know do you i mean you've
probably read it uh yes
i am a words i'm a words of affirmation
words of affirmations yours
what's yours yeah a physical touch oh
that's my husband's is it so do you find
that it's
um is it hard to do
to give him his because we tend to give
what we want to get right so you
probably give him tons of words of
affirmation
plenty of physical as much yes yes
hilarious
and i'm overstimulated by like
breastfeeding all night and everything
so i'm just like i bet
right um that's why i mentioned cuddling
because i'm thinking like
you know because being a physical touch
person i'm like and in bed you cuddle
of course right right in bed you don't
stop cuddling
my dad i was like this is really intense
he's like you first of all you have
three children my dad said
and then he goes and it's only hard for
the first 60 years so don't worry about
it
it's like oh my god but i remember
talking with elaine aaron
who wrote the highly sensitive person
and and i had just
um i had my son ever was born and
and i was talking with her about having
more kids and i hope i'm not speaking
out of school by sharing this
um but she basically was like be careful
as an hsp
having more than one child is incredibly
overstimulating
you know cut two i have three kids and
i'm
very overstimulated so tons of work
everything from like
album that just you know came out last
year to i mean broadway
holy crap i can't think of anything more
time and labor intensive than broadway
um
i mean planning a tour wow you really
fill your plate up
yeah there's some work addiction going
on and then there's also just this sort
of multi
what do we call us creatures us geminis
us multi-potential lights where i have
so many ideas and i'm happy to execute
them all i'm happy to complete them all
but it's just running out of time just
running out of time
i love that nature of a gemini just like
skim on the surface you know
know about so many different things and
like also
like a lot about some things but
definitely consuming so much information
i i love that constant research and that
that's
also what makes me a good candidate for
unschooling because
you know if my son or my daughter have
if they have any questions it's just you
know we're just always researching
do you homeschool your kids yeah you do
uh yeah we unschooled
that because i i feel like you know i
don't know if i'll ever have kids or not
but
um i'm like i don't think i'd want to do
it the traditional way like i don't i
don't know why i just don't
i don't know i just it doesn't seem
seems outdated it seems
like a lot of information that you don't
end up using again it seems really
restrictive from a travel standpoint
and anything and yeah yeah so
it's i mean i think of how hard it is
for people to be in a classroom and
you know some of us are really physical
like my parents used to say i would
never stop moving you know i was always
i'd be answering a question and twirling
and dancing and they'd say could you
just sit still for 10 seconds
um so yeah unschooling
i mean it's it's it's so hyper-intuitive
it's very comprehensive and
and it takes a lot of energy because
there's no
all right school starts at eight a.m and
is done at three
it's 24 7. so if if i have the energy
and my son asks me something at midnight
i'm answering it you know and we're
going to have that conversation
when i can but um i love it because
there's
such multiple interests and we we
loosely reference howard gardner's
multiple intelligence theory and
that helps you know so physically that
concept is
explaining that concept too either now
we're at the end
i want to hear about the school but
multiple intelligence is such a cool
concept
i totally believe in that it's helpful
because when people go oh that person's
so smart you know
my first question is like smart hot
smart how you know smart
physically smart musically smart
logically spark smart mathematically
naturalist intelligence people that have
a natural green thumb
um what are the other ones just
do i have it on my white board over here
i don't
um but yeah so i'm missing a few but i
remember asking howard gardner
if i audaciously could add a couple of
them you know and he said absolutely
because i think
comedic intelligence is actually a form
of intelligence
um linguistic word word play words like
paint
so i like that because i remember
watching someone do parkour once and he
and he in the interview after he said
you know people have always thought that
i wasn't very smart
and he goes i realized that my body was
really really really smart
and you know he's parkouring off of huge
buildings you know
and so i just love that he reframed it
you know because there are so many forms
of smart and
yeah maybe i'm not smart in one area you
know i can't
i'm not a gardener but i love math
you know and so so that way especially
with unschooling
we just loosely reference it you know so
if we've been baking a lot lately let's
go for a hike and if we've been
reading a lot lately let's create a game
from scratch or you know
but it is um it's intense and when i a
lot of my friends want to do it
and they're not in a position to be able
to do it and i completely respect that
anyone who's like oh my god i would
never do that i just think i completely
understand why you wouldn't
yeah what's the reason for for doing it
the way you do it and is there
a structure to it or is that sort of
more intuitive learning that you just
sort of keep chasing the balance of like
analytic versus creativity or something
like that
in your versus outdoor yeah the latter i
mean it's very much
follow the flow of the day so really
um so there winds up being
a semblance of a routine but there's no
rigidity to it
you know and we have a lot of tutors
come in and
my son's just launched his own
streetwear company
what he is pigeon legit for kids or for
adults
for both i'll get you a t-shirt
thanks but yeah i mean he's he's
expressed in so many different ways and
he's got ideas a mile a minute so for us
it's about
you know which which one are we going to
follow today
and then we bring in tutors if we need
to he takes gymnastics class he's
you know we just want to make sure that
all the itches that can be scratched are
scratched
with time being limited and it's a
resource thing too you know just
financially something to consider
because you know you can out you can
weigh both
like how much is tuition for certain
schools and
but then parents and caregivers you know
we want we want to be expressed and have
careers and work too
so yeah so what's the reason why why why
do you want to do it like that
well one of the main reasons was that i
was touring all the time
so i needed to have my family with me
because there was just i'm an attachment
family person right so there's no way
i'm gonna just not see them for six
months or
right like yeah it's not gonna happen so
that was the main impetus to begin with
but it was actually super intuitive
my parents are both teachers and my dad
was a principal forever
and and they taught everything from you
know first grade all the way into
college university so
so they have this whole sort of
wide-ranging perception of
what teaching even is and my dad would
just you know non-stop
teach me all the time to the point where
i'd have to say hey you know what
give me a minute i don't care if i
spelled that wrong you know and now my
son's doing that with me
and i say to my son you know i'm the
only one that's kind of
taking a peek over your shoulder around
this part so give me a break you know
he's like okay okay okay you can keep
doing it
but um so mostly it was for touring and
then the other part was really just that
it was intuitive i love
learning so much and ongoing education
that
when it's too formalized i think that's
great for
if you're trying to get your you know if
you want to become a doctor if you you
know
goes going to school is the greatest um
but for for some of the learning i think
really following what they need and what
i've noticed with my kids is that they
take breaks
really really naturally so my daughter
will be in the middle of something
that's a lot of activity a lot of color
a lot of everything and then
she'll just turn to me and say i'm just
gonna go lie down for a minute
and i'll go that's a great idea so it
feels like
they can chase their balance better
they're learning how to
they're learning how to they're learning
autonomy kind of
yeah and how to navigate their own
natural rhythm that's
right that's what i think it is it's you
know culture in so many ways with our
nine to five and our work addiction
our praising people that overwork
there's so many messages to go against
the body's natural rhythm right
so unschooling is super body rhythm so
if you wake up one day and you're like i
you know and they rarely if we have
things that are planned they rarely
cancel
so when they do we really honor it
like okay you know i really shouldn't be
there today
you know i feel like i've been thinking
a lot about this whole
um sort of everything that's going on in
this
world today and everything is structured
and the way that
in institutions operate and who's in
charge and everything and i'm like man
i feel like you know there and also i
went to egypt
um like a month ago and for a couple
weeks
and got an education there and learning
about
how what i'm going to say sort of like
was part of it was learned over their
experience but
this patriarchy that essentially what i
feel like happened was
in my opinion back in the egyptian days
you'll go and
we'll look at all these temples and
pyramids but really the temples are
where everything has the writing and the
hieroglyphs and
um the the the stories all included at
triad
which is a a man a woman and a child
and then essentially like it became the
trinity holy trinity and then women were
gone and the romans came in
and their religion and god i know
religion is so deep for you and goes
back
all the way to childhood what cradle
were you catholic
yeah um so
you know and it feels like the romans
came in and all this they they chipped
all the faces off of
everything in egypt like all the all the
beautiful you know
walls and everything they chip the faces
off and i'm like holy crap
it feels like that's kind of when the
patriarchy really like went
upswing and you know women were sort of
taken out of the equation for everything
everything was not only revised but you
know
all the men were writing it to their own
to suit their own
vision and ego and purpose
yeah yeah and i mean even the pervasive
message that there is such thing as
better than worse than whether it's
gender
or you know that beautiful book cast um
you know the idea that there's better or
worse is just pretty comical
doesn't mean you're not faster you're a
faster runner or driver or
doesn't mean it doesn't mean we don't
have different capacities it just means
the value our value is equal
you know i mean that's patriarchy's
completely
anathema to the idea of egalitarianism
it's
it's it's so violent
really atlantis it's violated patriarchy
tell me more about that
it feels like it's operating out of the
ego so much more like a woman just like
i've heard it a lot lately but then
every now and again there'll be
a man that will reflect it back and
they'll be like like
women just can do more you just have
more love you just have
more more more like you're just more of
things
and um at the core of it though just you
know creating and
and you know creating life and have just
more love inside it's not that you can't
a man can't love but women just kind of
lead with the heart a little bit more
and so if
like on the sort of like uh heels of you
talking about
how you how you um school your children
and how you teach them it's like
you're teaching them how to love
themselves too like and if we can shift
from more of a
patriarchal sort of mindset of like fit
in the box do this thing
get it done right like there's so much
rigidity to it
and um like women leading
are going to come from that heart space
of like love and compassion and softness
and honoring yourself and how you're
feeling and how you're doing that day
and letting the day lead you as opposed
to following this
like highly doctrine rigid curriculum
um where you start to have to detune and
detach from
yourself and your body and how you're
actually feeling
in order to operate like i know there's
such detachment and i think that part of
what we're moving into and i'm curious
if you think so
is into this space where we're learning
how to because we can't
how do we know what to trust do we trust
the news no do we trust the newspapers
no do we trust even documentaries
no who the heck paid for it right like
what was propaganda
like we don't even know what to trust
anymore and the only gauge we're going
to learn
that we need the one that we need to
learn how to use is our body
to give us the information and it does
and i think that only comes through
being able to tap into that
sort of the the feminine the femininity
within you
um and and that's just you know that's
that's woman
yeah and feminine even in man bodies and
non-gender identifying bodies too it's
like
the feminine is what has been murdered
by patriarchy
right yeah kind of the divine feminine
obviously i'm not trying to it's like
the femininity the divine feminine
versus within
within all of us so yes the the easiest
and
and quickest path to shifty patriarchy
is to
just start by being respectful to women
period let's just start there
um and then beyond that it's also just
honoring the vulnerable honoring the
the water of it all you know but i think
what's happened now with how
much stimulation there is in the world
depending upon our temperament
you know there's it just gets too much
in here like i think i think we can do
100 things and now it just feels like
there's 300 things so
and that's just me personally um so i i
like
i like that we have the capacity to
multitask
and um my projection is to be careful
with that
because then life can sometimes take
advantage of it and patriarchy
definitely will take advantage of it
it'll just say give us everything you've
got
and we'll take it and see you later so
um
but i think you know this is a really
great time to be alive as a woman
um and what i what i'm really keeping my
eye on
in my own personal world among many
other things is
is the the cluttering you know because
if i'm going to go meditate
there's a peter levine talks about i
think he calls it anxiety or sorry
meditation-induced anxiety or something
like that so those of us who go to
meditate
basically the point is is that with
certain trauma meditating is not going
to actually help
because then we're left alone with these
thoughts or these ruminations or these
tapes that play
so so sometimes meditating alone is
actually
not the way to go it depends on where
we're at i guess
i feel like i just went off on a great
tangent
oh it's it's all just it's the
exploration right it's it's trying to
figure it out it's trying to figure out
what you need and
you know i think that you do a really
good job of that and
um you know i think it's really cool
that you teach your kids i'm so
fascinated by all that
and and then you know like what we're
talking about with um
what's it multiple intelligence i mean
can you imagine if our world stepped
into a space where we all
learned what our intelligence was
instead of having to fit into a box like
i believe being biological beings that
there is a natural balance
not only is there a natural fix for
everything that is wrong with us and
nature
but also that we we are nature and that
we balance each other and so
imagine the beauty if we could all just
kind of contribute what we what was
what was what we were good at and
passionate about usually what we're
usually we're passionate about things
we're good at um and
and and how i feel i trust that there
would be a balance
in existence if we all just contributed
what we what was our natural
intelligence i really completely
agree with that yeah i think that all of
us expressing what we were here
to express is i mean makes it worth
being here
you know and if it's not if we're not
expressing who we are
then it's this it's still a play
it's still a presentation but it's it's
not um
it's just not so fun to be here if i'm
if i'm my ladder is leaned on
a different house you know it's like if
it's leaning in the in the direction
that
has me be able to show up and serve and
be expressed
and um feel
um then i'm then i'm in and i actually
think
the sensation in our bodies of inquiry
and going within i think that also
counters patriarchy because patriarchy
is so
out of body yeah it's very it's very
head at best
yeah um i love being in the head but um
but it has its role yeah i mean it's
like a
like a filter or a sieve or something
you know you know what i really wanted
to do
i don't know i would probably it's just
going to take too much time and i'll
have like 7 000 questions
for everyone but i wanted to go through
your albums and be like
what was the sort of catalyst and lesson
with each of them
but i don't know if we'll have let's
just go with the last one
let's just go with such pretty forks on
the road um so
why because you know you don't write
albums like on a
yearly basis or every other year it it
takes a while before i get my music from
you
i'm going to look at that i'm going to
really look at that no no it's all right
on time and it all is coming from
such an again organic place which i
think is why you've stood the test of
time and why
it you have such dedicated devotee
fans like myself because it's authentic
and you can't rush that right
yeah and so it's just gotta be natural
and flow so
what brought this one on this one was
postpartum
i started it in malibu with onyx and
i mean i think of the song losing the
plot
uh and diagnosis as me just going okay
so i feel really pathologized i feel
you know everything about postpartum
unless someone's experienced it it's a
tough one to explain i mean depression
and anxiety
is it's just become more ubiquitous now
so people have a general sense of what
you mean when you say depressed or
anxious
um postpartum in general have whole
other elements to it
of these invasive thoughts and
they're terrifying you know so it's um i
wanted to write
i needed to write to to tell the truth
about that about my experience
after having given birth to onyx my
daughter
and and then i kept going and there was
the disillusionment with okay i'm not a
21 year old in hollywood anymore what
does that mean
why am i here um am i you know the
am i gonna try and look 21 for the rest
of my life
probably not i mean clearly not um
and yeah these songs were some of them
were
retrospective so some of them were about
traumas sexual
abuse healing traumas and then some of
it was my relationship with los
angeles some of it was um a real
identity crisis of like
you know spiritually i know that a lot
of times a spiritual turning point for
people is
is like you said earlier when you're
kind of alchemically ground
into something challenging although i've
learned a lot of things without with
ease as well so
i want to give a moment to the to the
idea that we can learn things not just
through hardship too
fair totally fair um
but yeah is there any song on there that
you want me to talk about more
specifically or just
the whole record basically just yeah i
just think because i feel like there's
got to be an impetus on some level and
there's a
to to put you into the creative state
and that's what i'm curious about yeah
what
what starts it actually it's it's just a
little voice
the voice goes it's time
and then i go okay it's time to write a
record and then i figure out what studio
we're going to use and who who i want to
write it with
i love writing alone but i live to
collaborate so
mike farrell and i worked on this record
together and
i called it the piano record the whole
time because it was just us alone in a
room
with a piano and a mic so and then we
flushed it out with alex hope and
catherine marks both direct um
directing it i call it directing i
really think the music business would
benefit from that word because
sometimes producer producer makes sense
but i guess executive producer is what
they call director anyway
credits um well yeah
it just there's a turning point where
all it's
physical like it's time to write and if
i don't write i'm gonna get sick if i
don't express myself i'm gonna get
really depressed
so it's exciting and daunting when that
turning point comes
if all were equal i would love to put a
record out every two
every two years but now it's exciting
this new climate it's exciting and
daunting
is the idea of just kind of ongoingly
putting out music i remember
20 years ago i was like why don't why
don't we just put out a song whenever
you feel like it and
people are like oh lannis it doesn't
work like that it doesn't work like
that decades and decades of doing it
like this it's just fine don't
don't upset any apple cart yeah and then
um but now there it is so the pro
of it having been sort of one note
before was it would be touring
falling down and recovering and then
writing another record again and
rallying again and touring so it was
just this cycle
and there were times where i could in
theory be under the rock and hide under
there and
generate stuff under there um whereas
now
it's constant so it's not every four
years i'm doing something it's there's a
new song coming out next week there's
there's new songs and one-offs for lack
of a better term
um that are happening now so it's it's
constant expression and constant
generative and all these other areas
like animated shows and
you know there's you know speaking of
speaking of mania
the ideas don't stop basically so my
whiteboard is full
and then i have an incredible team
around me of people who are willing to
work with me or collaborate with me some
things like the musical taking eight or
nine years
you know and other things taking an
afternoon and recording it you know so
what's going on with the musical um the
musical
is coming back post pandemic i don't
know exactly the date but it'll come
back to broadway and then they're
opening in sydney
they're opening a jagged little pill
musical too that's so cool
yeah i have to ask maybe like my one of
my favorites or like
old school and i just have so many
memories um because i was
in england at the very beginning of my
stint there and the album had just come
out and i remember that's not like all i
played but when supposed former
infatuation junkie came out i was like
oh my gosh
that one seems so much it's so deep
um i'm curious what the impetus for that
was
it's like did you go to india and have
an experience
and meet some gurus and like i'm just so
curious because yeah
and or just like i just to me it's like
such a deep album
thank you no i that one was really
daunting to write because
a lot of people were wanting me in some
way whether they knew it or not they
were asking me to repeat
jagged little pill like make part two
right um
and also wherever i went grocery stores
anywhere the
the only question that was being posed
to me is when's your next record when's
your next record
and the more i heard that the more i
kind of
wound tight to be honest um and i
remember going to toronto to visit my
friend tim thorney and
my intention was to start to write
supposed
and the studio is set up beautiful
candles it was idyllic
and i turned to my friend tim and i said
i don't want to do this i don't want to
write i don't want to be here
and he was the first person who said
okay well then let's not write let's go
see a movie
you know we went to a movie we had a
sandwich
and then when we got back of course i
started writing because i just felt like
i had the freedom to write or not write
and you know i i thank my friend tim all
the time for
for just providing that space and
freedom to not write
you know so i had come back from india
and i had gone there to just sort of
step away from everything and
just be a brown haired girl from ottawa
canada again you know
and yeah i don't know if
india itself i mean it's a to me it's a
it's one giant altar you know everywhere
it just smells like an altar
everything is prayerful there and in
bali in certain places and probably
egypt where you just were too there's a
sense of soulfulness and spirit
that i wish we could sort of trickle
around the whole planet sometimes
but um but when i came back from that i
remember feeling
liberated somehow just somehow
the idea of going to india and letting
go
allowed me to just think okay well what
do you want to write what do i want to
write about what what do i care about
right now and
and that's it was almost like there was
a fork in the road at that moment am i
going to try
an attempt to repeat which i actually
don't even think i could do
i think if i tried to repeat i couldn't
do it um or am i going to just keep
seeing what comes and writing what is
happening you know
and i chose the latter and i'm so happy
i did yeah
would you think that it's uh because i
agree the idea that it would be possible
to just
do another jagged little pill album is
is um
you know might not even be possible is
there something you think that you left
behind
with that album personally that because
it's like
when we change the things we see change
right so like how could you can't really
you can't be that atlantis anymore
so what was it that changed from that
point
the turning point was to the degree that
ego was involved
and service it shifted
because my ego scratched that itch and
grabbed the brass ring and swallowed it
you know zeitgeist wise and you know
you know breaking records and all kinds
of
really heady sort of egoic things
and then i just thought well why would i
keep going because a lot of this is not
actually really enjoyable for me
my temperament um but i could see that
people in the audience people coming to
the shows were
being given permission in a way
permission to be human you know so i
thought well that's
i mean if someone were to ask me what on
my deathbed like
what was the most important thing is
just to be able to
offer love in macrocosmic ways and then
tiny microcosmic intimate ways you know
so i could see that through my career
and through expressing myself that
everything i valued was being imbued
into all of it
whatever i wrote whatever i performed
how i moved it was all informed by this
this idea of just wanting to show up you
know and and be of service and
and leave the room a little cleaner than
how you found it
that's a great gift do you feel that
that's your
purpose or what do you feel your purpose
is
just i think we're all unique filters
and we all have these quirky
intelligences and and abilities
and if we can hone in on who we are
to that degree what our talents are what
our capacities are then we can
work with those you know and then this
filter is
is contributing that it's kind of like
another another way of saying what you
said earlier which is that we're gonna
if we know who we are in terms of our
talents and our
intelligences then we can show up and
use them and then life's a little bit
more jumping out of bed in the morning
versus the daunting
you know no matter where we are even if
we kind of hate our job is there a way
for us to
to show up from this place of service
you know that just makes it all worth it
to me because otherwise
i don't think i'd i mean being in the
public guy is coolish
but i don't think i'd want to just stay
in the public eye randomly for no reason
and i think what's happened in the 70s
and 60s certainly ego was everywhere but
a lot of people were
you know wanting to be expressed and
that was part of what their fame story
was
but now it's like fame in and of itself
seems to be some kind of
end like fame is the check mark and i'm
like oh god it's just so
it's so hollow it's so lonely you know
um and i think it exacerbates anything
that was going on before fame so
if there were any insecurities or hyper
defensiveness or anything if that was
going on before fame
can almost be assured that it'll it'll
triple
as soon as uh as soon as fame comes into
the picture 100
i asked this question to someone else i
interviewed a little while back
and i asked whether or not we actually
ever
experience anyone else or we're only
always experiencing ourself through
other people
and so when you throw fame into it it's
like
it's like it's like it turns from a
little flame into
a blazing fire because there's so much
input there's so much information
coming at you and from fans from
people organizing your day to
you know family to friends it's like it
just gets so much and so much
information but it's really
i don't know do you i'm curious do you
think that do you know what i'm trying
to ask like do you think that given the
fact that
we are seeing everything through our own
filter and sort of
if flipping it projecting and being
triggered
essentially the whole time like in base
and it only has to do with your
orientation do you think we really ever
actually
experience anyone else truly or are we
just always experiencing ourself
or a varying degree of ourself well
there is no difference is the first
thought that came to me there's no
difference i mean there's a difference
between personality or
hair length or but there is no
difference you know
the whole metaphor of we're all a bunch
of snowflakes falling out of the same
cloud you know
so but i do believe
that there can be a state of awareness
and consciousness that is brought
where there can be a a real beholding i
do believe that's possible in the human
body
i do it doesn't it you know and
and it's i think the degree to which we
can stop the thoughts of assessing
and labeling and judging and those are
all normal things super normal
but if there can be some breaks or those
voices
get a little quieter and then we're just
sitting consciousness aware of
consciousness sitting
then we have this dire this direct
experience with what's across from us
whether it's a human or a bookshelf
or a light you know it becomes
very filled with wonder and awe you know
it's almost like if we're both looking
at a sunset
and there's birds flying we're just
having a direct experience no words just
direct
experience with that color or that
sensuality
and then if one of us goes oh it's 5 p.m
and the sun's about to go down all of a
sudden we're in the
we're in our head about it it's not as
direct of an experience with that so
so as best as i can if i if i can tell
that i'm just projecting all over my
husband or
or my friends which i do every day um
um getting really really still and just
beholding almost like we're a martian
that just landed here which by the way
is
it's not that far from being able to
happen but but it's like it's like
landing on this earth for the first time
and
you ever have that where you're on an
airplane or you're driving hello
and you're just like how's this even
possible that i can go this fast in the
air in a tin thing
i i literally look up to this guy and
see an airplane and go
why would we think it was so weird if it
was an extraterrestrial craft like why i
mean that thing's flying through the air
yeah so i mean to me that's you know
approaching life with that kind of
wonder and that kind of
mind-blown-ness you know people are like
if you could just be one emoji what
would it be i was like
the mind-blown emoji my mind is
constantly freaking blown that's
beautiful
well it comes through and you know your
music resonates with so many
so i'm grateful for your process and
thank you for
sharing and and opening your heart and
being vulnerable and
you know i love hearing stories about
you know hearing a story about writing
like back in the day and it being like
asked you whether or not it was true or
not and you're like yeah it's
true and like yeah it's well then it's
not coming out of the
lyrics right i'm not gonna ask your
favorite song because i don't think
that's very easy it's like a child right
but
is there one that you were the most
afraid to
release that felt the most vulnerable
well hands clean is a song about
basically statutory rape um the the
record company people were like oh let's
do a video where it's karaoke with
little with some
some kids in there and i remember saying
did you
listen to the song
you know apparently not everyone is a
lyric person so when hands clean came
out i got terrified
about thinking that that would require
me
to speak more often on you know this was
however many
15 years 10 years before me too happened
maybe
so i was scared my palms were sweaty but
i'm always scared
i'm never not scared i mean
i don't think i'm ever not afraid
doesn't mean i'm not going to do it
that's good advice right there
thank you for that i will take that and
run with it
yes you already have by the way drive
with it
wait time's over no more driving yeah
what's next few oh my god i want to
interview you
anytime anytime well thank you thank you
so much
and you know i'm just such a giant fan i
can't wait for you to go on tour
i won't tell you when i'm showing up but
come back after
although i'm you know someone will know
and i'll probably figure out tickets so
somebody might know
just wear a wig thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button